[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire je reçois aujourd'hui pour
cette première émission culturelle de la
rentrée la politologue virginie martin
qui publie le charme discret des séries
pour elle les séries ne sont pas
seulement des fictions divertissante et
chronophage elles veulent changer le
monde je recevra ensuite mélodies
mourrait pour sa nouvelle pièce la
course des géants au théâtre des béliers
parisien c'est sur la conquête spatiale
des années 60 et la rivalité américano
soviétique et carole plaidons le premier
rhdp est sorti en mars et qui fait
horreur l'ouverture vendredi prochain du
festival et saône en scène domaine
partement tel de chamarande et l'on
commence tout de suite par vos vieux
philippe martin voici la photo que vous
avez choisie pour illustrer notre époque
je la reconnais les vous dans l'émission
c'est aux relents
bien sûr si l'on
multifaces multi facettes comme
d'habitude aux relents voilà oui pour
moi c'est un petit peu l'époque
l'hybridité le travail corps l'ont fait
à la fois sur son corps qui sait
décrypter magnifiquement l'environnement
qui travaille sur la créolisation elle
travaille à la fois sur des substances
animales humaines technologiques donc
voilà je trouve qu'elle saisit très bien
l'époque et je trouve que c'est une
rentrée septembre 2021 très très
contemporaine et ça pourrait être un
personnage de série à
mais bien sûr bien sûr c'est même un
personnage de série évidemment
évidemment comme donna haraway dans
certaines séries d'ailleurs un peu
dystopique la féministe donna haraway
orlan pour être en tant que plasticienne
donc presque toutes les séries elle est
une série à elle toute seule d'ailleurs
sa carrière très longue aujourd'hui le
prouve elle s'est mise elle même en
scène tout au long de sa carrière et ce
qu'elle a fait est extraordinaire de
modernité de finesse et un trail la fois
anthropologique quasi dystopique aussi
pour moi elle est une série à lui tout
seul alors le chamin le charme discret
des séries est paru chez human sciences
pour vous les séries ne sont pas
anodines ce ne sont pas seulement des
programmes divertissants et addictif ce
sont des objets politiques et des objets
très puissant
oui ce sont d'abord des objets
effectivement distrayant forcément parce
que beaucoup d'émotion bien entendu mais
après derrière cela il ya beaucoup de
messages beaucoup de messages et comme
vous le dites aussi avec des plateformes
surpuissante donc forcément les messages
sont forcément très fort puisqu'ils
peuvent concerner 500 milles 1 million 2
3 4 millions de personnes simultanément
ce qui est énorme et comme ça passe par
l'émotionnel c'est encore plus fort
parce que ça arrive vraiment à nous
atteindre un message politique est
toujours bien plus fort quand il passe
par la douceur ou peut-être la colère ou
la joie ou l'amour ou la passion c'est
très important et ça vient du coup à la
fois prendre le coeur mais aussi notre
sur moi politique si je puis dire vous
dites 2 3 4 millions mais j'ai besoin de
vous sur est sous-estimé l'espérer les
plus puissantes je rappelle qu'il doit y
avoir à peu près 200 millions d'abonnés
à à netflix aujourd'hui il ya certaines
séries qui sont vus par la plupart
d'entre eux donc sur la longueur même si
tout le monde ne les regarde pas au même
moment sur la longueur ça doit être ce
chiffre est en plusieurs dizaines de
millions de téléspectateurs et qui les
regardent extrêmement assidûment un
puisque c'est un il ya un nouveau
phénomène en plus avec les plateformes
c'est ce que vous appelez le beam
switching
on se connaissait le binge drinking mais
qu'est ce que c'est le beam switching
le beach watching c'est vraiment regardé
en fait de manière boulimique des séries
en boucle avec ce côté un peu un fini on
définitive que les plateformes nous
propose puisque c'est finalement le
streaming la grande différence entre le
streaming d'aujourd'hui via les
plateformes et les épisodes qu'on a pu
connaître de dallas à l'époque c'est
quoi c'est que c'est infini je peux
passer d'une saison à une autre d'une
série à une autre et si j'ai épuisé
toute la plate forme je peux aller sur
une autre plateforme m'abonner aussi
donc il ya le benchmark shing c'est quoi
c'est regarder cinq six sept huit heures
12 heures 14 heures de série à la suite
et ne jamais jamais s'en lasser et de
passer toujours d'une à l'autre comme
cela et voilà donc le phénomène on vous
parlez vous avez par une puissance au
début de l'émission le phénomène est
d'une puissance incroyable alors les
séries et c'est sans doute aussi pour ça
que ça vous a intéressé en tant que
politologue bien finie martin c'est du
soft power on le voit bien alors les
américains sont évidemment les grands
maîtres mais les britanniques sont très
très forts aussi notamment dans les
séries historiques quand un succès
énorme dans dans le monde entier les
russes ils sont mis israël est
extrêmement
prolifique également avec des séries qui
s'exporte très bien ou qui sont adaptées
dans les autres pays l'espagne depuis
quelque temps fede fait un tabac
notamment depuis le succès de la casa de
papel la france est un peu à la traîne
un il ya le bureau des légendes qui a eu
beaucoup de succès qui s'est très bien
exportée il ya 10% qui est plus anodines
mais il n'y a pas encore de très très
gros on a l'impression qu'on sait pas
très bien il faire nous c'est un peu
comme si en fait on ne voulait pas se
saisir véritablement de l'objet
politique que sont les séries en fait
c'est ça l'histoire c'est à dire que
quand on fait un un arsène lupin
avec omar sy vous voyez qu'on est sur
power à la française avec un pari
magnifique les musées les rues pavées
les appartements haussmanniens alors
certes omar sy à la peau noire mais
quelque part c'est presque un peu
anecdotique si je puis dire même si
l'extrême droite s'est énervé là dessus
mais c'est quand même pas là où on
travaille le plus ya comme quelque chose
de me garder finalement l'image d'une
france qui affiche le luxe ses comédiens
et comédiennes vous avez parlé de la
série 10% mais finalement est-ce qu'on
prend le politique vraiment comme on
pourrait le prendre raconter l'histoire
vraiment de notre pays avec une volonté
d'exporter une image différente que
celle d'un des bijoux qu'on peut trouver
au louvre et qu'on peut aller voler
subrepticement il ya quelque chose qui
manque un petit peu en france et en
europe d'une manière générale par
l'europe d'ailleurs n'existe pas en
termes vraiment de production européenne
a très peu et pourtant les séries à vous
entendre façonnent le monde de demain
elles sont d'abord parce qu'elles sont
beaucoup regarder ensuite parce qu'elles
sont très politiques et sur tous les
plans par exemple elle nous montre des
femmes
alors beaucoup plus que le cinéma en
réalité elle nous montre des femmes
fortes des femmes bien intégré
professionnellement des femmes
responsables des femmes très différentes
les unes des autres il y en a des
petites et des grandes d'émincés des
rondes des jeunes et des plus âgés il y
en a des brunes des rousses des blondes
des dés qu'ils ont les cheveux blancs
des noirs des asiatiques des blanches ça
c'est totalement nouveau le cinéma nous
avait habitués à quelque chose de
beaucoup plus normé oui le cinéma était
beaucoup plus stéréotypé au regard des
femmes ou si souvent plus sexualisée
puissance ua lisez là tout d'un coup les
les femmes sont devenus des êtres
humains comme les autres il sait très
agréable c'est très agréable c'est aussi
pour ça que le public féminin est très
attaché à ses séries parce qu'un
processus d'identification qui est
possible mais derrière l'explication
c'est quoi ces cônes a évidemment des
fagnes herrero on a à la manette des
femmes en fait on a des champs d'aram
c'est évidemment on a des biches des
virginie brac pour la france donc ça
c'est très important on a des défis
bille ou à l'heure donc c'est très
important parce que tout d'un coup ce
sont aussi des femmes qui sont aux
manettes et une des héroïnes enfin
l'héroïne d'ailleurs de la servante
écarlate disait pendant la remise de
prix lors d'une cérémonie
maintenant c'est nous les femmes qui
écrivons les histoires qui écrivons
aussi des histoires et donc du coup
forcément les histoires ressemble à ces
histoires de femmes qui sont voilà qui
met qui se met quelque part en scène à
travers ces séries ce que au cinéma on a
peut-être beaucoup moins vu par le passé
bien sûr alors il ya les femmes qui
bénéficient des séries et les minorités
aux siens toutes les minorités on voit
bien l'importance de la communauté
afro-américaine dans les séries
américaines comme l'importance
d'ailleurs des arabo musulman dans les
séries françaises
oui absolument alors aux etats unis
c'est carrément une énorme série comme
comme green leaf
qui a été produite par oprah winfrey
donc il ya vraiment à une sorte de
militantisme même j'allais dire à aller
comme ça mettre en scène une communauté
afro-américaine qui peut être aussi en
très grande réussite grande réussite
professionnelle financière le temps est
loin avec des greens if par exemple des
noirs américains qui sont forcément au
fin fond des prisons là on est dans
quelque chose aussi les représentations
tout d'un coup sont bousculés et ça
c'est très bien en france sur les
communautés arabo musulmane on est
encore un petit peu dans une caricature
souvent quoique il ya la série les
sauvages qui est très intéressant de ce
point de vue là qui est une série d'une
richesse extrême avec une finesse
politique et sociale très importante
les sauvages porte en fait roschdy zem
le kabyle surdiplômés à la tête de la
france donc jusqu'au palais de l'elysée
mais évidemment il sera aussi rattrapé
par ses racines de la banlieue de
saint-etienne par l'extrême droite aussi
donc c'est une série très subtil et très
intéressante mais plus à l'américaine
j'allais dire un peu plus fonctionner un
peu plus mises en glamour si je puis
dire il n'y a pas que des hétéros dans
les séries a beaucoup de mots beaucoup
de be l'ebit sont mais extrêmement
nombreux beaucoup de transe au cirfa
beaucoup il ya pas mal de transe ya là
beaucoup plus que dans le cinéma en tout
cas bien sûr et puis aussi là c'est
pareil c'est comme les femmes ou les
personnages afro américains ou ou arabo
musulman c'est à dire qu'il ya aussi une
volonté de banalisation en fac de ses
présences là il peut y avoir des séries
vraiment comme pause où effectivement la
question homosexuels transsexuels est
vraiment centrale mais il peut y avoir
aussi des séries ici ou là qui banalise
complètement et qui font rentrer en
définitive la question de la
transexualité notamment complètement
dans le quotidien c'est le cas par
exemple de orange is the new black qui
sort donc en 2014 et qui met un
personnage donc transsexuels au fin fond
de cette prison de femmes et donc ça
pose la question évidemment de la nudité
du rapport au sexe dans ces prisons où
l'intimité évidemment n'existe pas et là
c'est vraiment très intéressant mais on
voit aussi sa dans american horror story
où on voit un couple de lesbiennes être
en prise avec l'adoption et puis on le
voit aussi peut-être plus mainstream
dans tf1 dans une série qui s'appelle
ici tout commence et qui met en scène un
couple l'a22 chef cuisinière qui sont
toutes les deux lesbiennes ayant bien
passé la cinquantaine et qui finalement
se retrouve dans une histoire d'amour
donc vous voyez c'est il ya une volonté
de ne pas mettre en exergue de manière
exceptionnelle mais de le mettre dans la
quotidienneté et puis elle est malade
dans autrefois dans les vieilles séries
du xxème siècle il y avait l'homme de
fer qui étaient dans un fauteuil roulant
où il y avait match contre la vie avec
ben gazzara qui avait une maladie qui
qu' une maladie qui allait le tuer il ne
restait jamais beaucoup de temps là
maintenant sur des maladies qu'on ne
voit pas mais ces débats-là dit
généralement beaucoup plus
qui touche le cerveau il ya des gens qui
souffrent de handicap terrible il ya des
bipolaires il ya des schizophrènes il ya
une richesse aussi du côté des maladies
qui étaient tout à fait nouvelle oui
effectivement là aussi un c'est un peu
comme si notre quotidien avait le droit
de rentrer dans l'univers des séries
alors évidemment il est fictionné il ya
un peu glamouriser mais aussi permet
certainement une identification dans
orangis nieuwblad donc je parlais tout à
l'heure il y à une dame qui est qui et
qui est en fait un cancer très avancé et
on voit ça à sa déchéance physique si je
puis dire il ya des questions qui sont
liées autour de l'autisme
il y à des quais des handicaps à la fois
très visible on peut être effectivement
en chaise roulante comme dans la série
de tf1 qui se passe à 7 et qui s'appelle
donc demain nous appartient mais il peut
y avoir aussi des handicaps plus
invisible plus plus sournois c'est
évidemment le personnage de carrie dans
homeland qui est dit donc bipolaire et
voilà mes médias il n'ya pas ce que je
veux dire c'est toujours pareil c'est en
fait il est tous et toutes ces maladies
tout c'est ont tous ces handicaps sont
mis dans une quotidienneté bien sûr
glamouriser mais dans une quotidienneté
ça existe tout simplement et alors moi
ce qui m'a toujours frappé en ce qui
concerne les séries pourquoi elles sont
devenues intéressante pourquoi on s'est
mis à regarder tous des séries a parlé
des séries bien plus qu'on ne parle de
six débats aujourd'hui à partir du
tournant du 20e et 21e siècle c'est
qu'elles sont devenues immoral les
séries était édifiante autrefois elles
deux elles étaient assez paternaliste on
peut dire aujourd'hui elles sont
immorales les héros sont souvent
immoraux elle ajoute à la complexité du
monde elle n'essaye pas de simplifier
comme autrefois c'est vrai qu'elles
ajoutent à la complexité du monde quand
on prend car il justement dont je
parlais dans homeland par deux fois elle
est à deux doigts de tuer sa propre
fille
emprise à ses doutes professionnel à sa
pression professionnelle et bien tout
d'un coup elle n'apparaît pas comme la
maman parfaite la maman idéalisée elle
donne un bain à sa fille à un moment
donné et est ce que je la noix je la
dois pas on voit bien qu'à dépenser
comme ça parasite qui viennent en fait
la troubler les personnages politiques
aussi sont très immoraux bon on s'en
doutait un peu là mais c'est vrai que
quand on voit des barreaux noirs quand
on voit évidemment
des séries politique à l'américaine avec
un personnage très très très important
et très mise en scène on voit bien
effectivement les comment dire les
tourments de l'être humain oui on
n'essaye pas de nous croire de nous
faire croire que le bien règne ou qu'il
n'ya plus ligne à que le bien et le mal
on voit bien que tout est toujours
beaucoup plus compliqué et on nous
apprend à
sympathiser à aimer même des des
personnages qui sont parfois on m'avait
absolument temps qu'on vous prenez
scandale il faut vraiment voir cette
série qui est passionnante scandale de
shonda rhimes justement qui met le
personnage d'olivia potes en scène
qu'est ce que c'est c'est une grande
lobbystes une grande professionnelle de
la communication qui va rentrer à la
maison blanche c'est un personnage
auquel on s'accroche énormément et le
président des états unis aussi qu'est
mise en scène on s'y accroche énormément
et en même temps en temps des très
troublé parce qu'ils sont toujours à la
limite effectivement sur une espèce de
ligne de crête entre le bien le mal
jusqu'où re dois les aimer et bien voilà
il ne sont le reflet fidèle n'ont que de
nouvelles et de nos complexité alors de
quoi parle-t-elle toutes ces séries mais
elle parle de politique elle parle de
géopolitique elle parle du contrôle elle
parle de la surveillance il parle de
l'état elle parle du populisme beaucoup
de la corruption de l'écologie
énormément de l'animal isme même des
privilèges des ultra-riches les
ultra-riches vous le faites remarquer
dans votre livre sont souvent condamnés
oui les ultra ultra le riche en fait
surtout ceux qui font peut-être partie
des 0 5% de la planète et qui vivent
hors sol qui ne sont plus tellement
finalement fiscalisant fiscalisés dans
un lieu qui ne mettent plus leurs
enfants dans des écoles véritablement
qui les changent tous les 5 minutes au
gré des classements internationaux qui
prennent des jets plutôt qu'un tgv qui
ont des chauffeurs en voilà des gens qui
ont qui se sont vraiment déracinés dans
cette espèce de cosmopolitisme pour le
meilleur mais aussi parfois pour le pire
puisque ces gens n'être plus finalement
la planète terre au contraire ils s'en
servent et il a des cernes et là c'est
très montrer l'environnement vous en
avez parlé de manière concomitante est
aussi vraiment montré en disant
attention à les séries lasson lanceuse
d'alert ces dystopies souvent
environnementales sont vraiment lanceuse
d' alerte en disant attention au nez
dans la colle absolue j comme dirait ce
qu'ils ont fait donc l'effondrement les
parasites pour ne pas les nommer et là
il ya quelque chose qui dit faites
attention notre planète nos super riches
notre europe l'autoritarisme la société
de surveillance le super internet black
mirror pour le meilleur encore une fois
mais pour le pire aussi bien entendu
puisque on n'est pas loin évidemment dû
surveiller et punir chère à michel
foucault mais tout ça bien fini est ce
qu'à votre avis et du marketing au fond
est-ce qu'on donne aux téléspectateurs
ce qui ce dont il a envie est ce qu'on
lui donne tout ça parce qu'au fond les
autres ne le font pas donc on va aller
chercher dans les séries ce qu'on ne
trouve plus au cinéma où il ya plus que
des super héros et des comédies gnangnan
ou est ce que véritablement il ya un
message il ya une une philosophie ya un
progressisme au fond qui aujourd'hui
surnage dans la série quand il est en
train de disparaître ailleurs
on peut pas dire qu'il n'ya pas de
marketing ce serait vraiment naïf de
penser qu'il n'ya pas de marketing avec
ces mastodontes financiers que sont ce
que j'appelle les dan c'est-à-dire
disney amazon netflix
bien sûr on peut pas dire ce sont juste
de gentils de gentilles personnes qui
veulent à une société d'inclusion mais
en même temps mais en même temps quand
on voit notamment netflix et toute sa
communication sur les diversités sûr si
tu as pas envie de voir de guet sur
notre plate forme et bien résilient ton
abonnement il ya une politique très
agressive au sian en termes de
communication chez netflix là-dessus
leurs charges et de diversité est
quelqu'un qui était assez proche des
mouvances de bernie sanders qui est
assez proche de de house etc est assez
proche de 2 kamala harris pendant toute
cette gauche un peu américaine voire par
une vraie gauche américaine on va dire
donc on voit bien qu'il ya quand même
aussi des personnages militants dans les
créateurs aussi dans les producteurs
aussi donc il ya quand même à la fois
une volonté de réussite financière à
l'américaine aussi une volonté de
ressembler à la rue pour me faire vite
mais aussi de dire mais voilà l'amérique
que nous voulons ils ont fait un travail
colossal par exemple les américains
contre 30 mai un travail vraiment de
sape au sens strict du sterne un travail
politique
mais en même temps avant trump du temps
de george bush les séries étaient quand
même très très pro genre je bouge trop
patriot act pro intervention en irak pro
intervention en afghanistan
donc on peut le voir des deux côtés
alors on peut voir et d'écouter c'est à
dire que pour l'instant aujourd'hui ce
sont plutôt des forces dites
progressistes qui sont à la manette en
fait de ces séries mais c'est certain
mais met par exemple l'acteur qui joue à
boire dans
dans 24h 24 ans qu'on nous dit justement
mais c'est bizarre parce qu'on est
arrivé en plein milieu grosso modo du 11
septembre et les républicains se sont
emparés de cette série alors que nous
nous avions un message plutôt
progressistes et démocrates donc vous
voyez les séries sont aussi accueillis
en contexte elles sont filtrées aussi
par par l'environnement par l'actualité
du moment où ça c'est important aussi de
le voir et donc là c'est à la fois une
conjonction de plein de choses bien
entendu des progressistes et des
nationalistes donc en europe qui se
battent entre eux et puis un train
versus donc un bail donne aux états unis
qui se battent entre eux un maudit en
inde 1ère dogan en turquie évidemment
donc il ya aussi tous là vous voyez donc
ça rentre finalement à résonance avec
quel monde nous voulons demain c'est
très simple
c'est un monde
avant que certains chroniqueurs en
france appellent de leurs voeux ou c'est
un monde d'après qui serait plus
inclusif plus complexes et peut-être
plus diversifiée ou plus sauvages si si
le réchauffement climatique tient ses
promesses si l'on peut dire et sans le
voit avec toutes les séries collapse
logique de the walking dead d'ailleurs
quitte une série sur les zombies à
toutes les séries qui nous montre des
séries post apocalyptique qui au fond
nous montre toujours la même chose
c'est-à-dire l'être humain réduit à ses
instincts tout à coup on va redevenir
comme nos ancêtres préhistoriques et on
va se battre pour un peu d'essence ou
pour un morceau de viande oui absolument
les séries que la biologie que son sont
vraiment pléthore pléthore de cesser
certains c'est vraiment un gros tels des
séries dans le même temps ce qui est
intéressant c'est notamment les
parasites avec l'effondrement un petit
peu poussé en cela par
le philosophe pablo service qui a dit la
tension dans ces moments là aussi de
grand theft ondes heureusement il peut y
avoir aussi de nouvelles solidarités qui
se met en place et ça c'est important
aussi c'est à la fois la survie
peut-être la bagarre on va peut-être
centre voler un demi litre d'essence
mais aussi peut-être des communautés de
solidarité qui vont se mettre en place
et ce qu'on voit d'ailleurs dans
l'effondrement qu'est ce qu'on peut voir
aussi ici ou là dans certaines séries
c'est peut-être plus rares pour
l'instant en termes de mise à l'écran
mais c'est peut-être une voix que l'on
peut explorer aussi quand il ne reste
plus rien peut-être qu'il est
injustement de refaire des tribus mais
au sens positif du terme on voit bien
que les séries participe de notre peur
de la fin du monde mais aussi de notre
rejet de la démocratie parce que les
séries politique nous montre tout un
personnel politique totalement soient
corrompus soient soit malfaisants tout
simplement de notre d'un autre n des
ultra-riches vous avez dit pourquoi 2 on
pourrait énumérer
au fond elle épouse à peu près tout les
hantises de notre époque elle l'est les
caresse dans le sens du poil
les épouses elles les époux c'est
certain mais en même temps elles nous
disent attention donc c'est quand même
bien en termes de prise de conscience
d'une part le petit regret qu'on peut
avoir c'est peut-être dans les séries
politique quand j'essaye politique c'est
vraiment au sens strict 1 c'est victime
justement marseille ou baron noir pour
ne pas les citer là on voit qu'il ya pas
de grands récits politiques qui sont
mises en scène qui sont mises en série
et ça c'est très dommage on ne pourrait
attendri par exemple à 15 années papel
pourquoi elle a été been choix che à ce
point là parce que c'est une série
romantique aux politiques c'est ça quel
fabuleux dans la casa des papin même si
c'est bien sûr irréaliste mais quelque
part ça redonne un peu d'espoir ça
raconte un peu quelque chose ça nous
fixe yonne l'avenir politique
potentiellement possible et ça c'est
intéressant c'est pour ça c'est tandis
que quand une série est aussi clinique
aussi
malsaine dans ce qu'elle met en scène
les suicides des malversations d'argent
etc comme baron noir c'est à la fois une
vérité politique mais ça manque de deux
choses ça manque d'une hotte vérité
politique est aussi l'honnêteté le
militantisme la générosité et
l'altruisme que ce que c'est que de
s'engager en politique aussi est
puissamment quand même deux récits de
respiration c'est un peu comme si
c'était la fin du politique
et ça c'est problématique parce que déjà
que la fin du politique est presque à
nos portes quand on regarde la droite et
à gauche autour de nous mais là les
séries nous confions une sorte de sphère
du politique quand la case aide et
appelle au contraire nous redonne un peu
d'oxygène et on retrouve de l'oxygène
finalement dans les dystopie de dieu
attention ce qu'il ne faut pas faire
elles disent pas toujours ce qu'il faut
faire et c'est là que siri le récit
politique manque l'iman mille manque
aussi chez les intellectuels il manque
chez les politiques est évidemment
immense chez les créateurs de syrie le
charme discret des séries
le livre de virginie martin vient de
paraître chez humaines sciences merci
virginie ont fait une pause on se
retrouve juste après avec mélodie mouret
[Musique]
mais ledit mort et vous êtes l'auteur et
vous avez fait la mise en scène de la
course des géants qui joue au théâtre
des béliers parisien tous les soirs à
21h c'est une pierre une pièce sur la
course à la lune entre les américains et
les soviétiques dans les années 60 mais
d'abord on va regarder la photo vous
avez choisi pour symboliser notre époque
parce qu'une photo qui viennent nous
vient de l'espace le site nettement
c'est une photo prise par thomas pasquet
depuis l' iss c'est une des dernières
qui là qu'il a posté qui si on peut voir
l'ouragan ida way qui a dévasté la
louisiane hier et voilà thomas pasquet
sensibilise beaucoup aux questions
climatiques à la crise depuis l'espace
en montrant en entendait des incendies à
des des tempêtes
l'espace ça vous intéresse depuis
longtemps où c'est pour cette pièce où
c'est thomas pesquet peut-être qu'il ya
eu cette influence sur vous
oui je suis avec beaucoup de beaucoup de
passion à thomas pasquet mais
non c'est c'est vraiment en me
documentant pour écrire cette pièce que
je me suis plongé dans l'histoire la
conquête spatiale et que je me suis
intéressé vous étiez venu dans cette
émission pour votre première pièce les
crapauds fou qui avait beaucoup de
succès c'était sur l'extermination des
juifs polonais par les nazis la course
des géants c'est encore une épopée avec
30 personnages interprétés par six
comédiens j'ai l'impression que vous
marchez sur les traces de delixi
michalik
alors oui parce qu'il ya beaucoup
d'acteurs sur le plateau et puis et puis
un montage il ya un cadrage il ya vous
fait la course avec le cinéma et avec
les séries d'ailleurs d'autant viennent
parler plus qu'avec shakespeare
oui effectivement il ya un an il ya
d'humain rythme qui est proche de celui
des séries le fait que les acteurs aussi
jouent plusieurs rôles permet de passer
web de passer d'un lieu à un autre si
donc effectivement ça c'est quelque
chose qui retrouve pas mal au cinéma et
dans les séries il ya beaucoup
d'ellipses beaucoup de jam cut il ya du
cadrage dit parce que au fond vous nous
montrer quelque chose à un moment dans
le décor qui va nous servir la ronde et
à la nasa dans la photo qui est là
l'instant d'après on va être sur un
terrain d'aviation ont peut être un peu
n'importe où dans votre théâtre on saute
d'un endroit à l'autre et c'est trés cut
d'où le doubs le jam cut tout ça c'est
nouveau dans le théâtre c'est très 21e
siècle
oui c'est assez nouveau bah oui vous
l'avez dit c'est vrai que les pièces d
alexis michalik un peu
lancé ses nouveaux ces nouveaux codes
narratifs au théâtre on les retrouve
comme dans beaucoup de beaucoup de
caisses maintenant
je pense que vos pièces de pauline
bureau enfin plein plein plein de pièces
maintenant utilisent c'est qu'au-delà
qui correspondait au rythme de ce qu'on
est habitué à voir ce qu'on aime voir en
tant que spectateur
jack mans si nice est le héros de cette
pièce d'un gamin pauvre rebelles et
surdoué qui va devenir pilote et vivre
la conquête spatiale est ce que vous
êtes inspiré de quelqu'un alors je me
suis très librement inspiré oui de la
vie notamment de cannes mattingly qui
devait partir sur la mission apollo xiii
qui finalement à quelques jours du
lancement a appris qu'il ne pourrait pas
partir oui il était censé avoir la
rougeole 1 on le voit dans le film ap le
13 d'ailleurs il y avait pas gagné si
naïve oui absolument et donc ça c'est
voilà je me suis librement inspiré de de
son histoire
mais jack mancini un héros complètement
inventé avec un passé inventé une
enfance très difficile qui n'est pas
celle de cannes mattingly voilà ces
errements un point de départ il ya eu
pas mal de séries de films mais aussi de
série sur la conquête spatiale et sur la
rivalité américano soviétique mais au
fond il ya un aspect qu'on aborde très
peu que vous abordez vous ces
l'espionnage et
et vous une affaire d'espionnage
entre les soviétiques et les américains
ça c'est assez c'est assez pour accéder
à la place la personne d' a tellement
travaillé là dessus oui c'est vrai je
fais de croiser un peu une histoire
d'espionnage avec une histoire de
conquête spatiale avec aussi l'ascension
sociale
c'est un pan mais un mélange des genres
un mix nouveau et est ce que le j'ai
l'impression que la conquête spatiale en
soit sur une pièce de textures à une
scène de théâtre ça paraît absurde mais
après tout robert hossein a bien fait
ben-hur
alors je me souviens plus où il avait
fait au parc des princes je crois mais
c'est lui qui avait lancé sa de pouvoir
faire vous êtes peut-être un peu jeune
mais il faisait le cuirassé potemkine il
faisait des tatas qu'on imaginait pas au
théâtre je crois pas qu'il ait fait la
conquête spatiale mais au fond de
l'impression que yao 15 sujet
aujourd'hui qu'ils ne puissent rentrer
sur une scène de théâtre oui c'est vrai
est ce qu'un un défi quand même c'est
vrai que au moment de l'écriture je
pensais pas forcément beaucoup à la mise
en scène donc il ya eu quand même un
moment je me suis dit bon est-ce que ça
va ce que ça va être possible de
représenter sa et s'est permis par par
la scénographie qui est très très
ingénieuse d'olivier prost avec avec des
écrans la vidéo la musique aussi qu'il
accompagne beaucoup beaucoup toute
l'histoire et qui nous permet de qui
permet de nous projeter dans les étoiles
sans problème on va regarder il ya un
petit teaser assez court d'ailleurs
celui des des crapauds fou était
beaucoup plus long pourquoi est-ce que
celui là vous avez choisi si court parce
qu'on n'a pas encore fait devraient
captation ce qui avait permis de faire
donc c'est par manque d'image donc
accepter ça commençait seulement juillet
oui et au fond ces bateaux qu'elle
démarre vraiment la rentrée on regarde
quand même le teaser même s'il est
encore un peu court
jeanny beijing qui sera alimenté à
ceyrat min
je veux être astronaute
astronautes
oui
vous ne connaissez pas boston et vous
voulez aller voir la lune
pourquoi est ce que vous seriez
sélectionné par la nasa parce que je
serai le meilleur et qui paraît que se
paient récompense le mérite je donne je
crois qu'on a eu un problème
d'où ce nom un problème
les crapauds fou avec beaucoup de succès
en plus avait été nommé trois fois aux
molière
est ce que la course des géants vous
avez l'impression d'en bénéficier
on vous fait confiance
et est ce que le public arrive sans
attendre 8 complètement là on est on est
très heureux et aussi surpris de
l'accueil des faux spectacle on est
complet tous les soirs et je pense
qu'effectivement le fait que le public
et est apprécié les crapauds fou nous
adocia lancer la pièce on est encore au
tout début
vous aviez vu j'imagine le film apollo
13 c'est lui qui vous inspirent au
départ parce que là les histoires
d'apollo 13 pour ceux qui n'ont pas vu
un film c'est une mission apollo qui va
tourner à la catastrophe et il ya
effectivement un personnage important
qui n'est pas dans la capsule qu'il faut
absolument ramener sur terre qui est
celui qui devait partir et qui a eu la
rougeole c'est en tout cas dont on
craignait qu'il est la rougeole qui va
se retrouver lui au sol et qui va aider
ses camarades à revenir parce qu'il
connaît la capsule aussi bien que et le
film a eu beaucoup de succès il ya déjà
avec tom hanks est déjà une presque une
vingtaine d'années je crois
j'imagine que c'est seul point de départ
oui complètement soir mes films préférés
il y avait clairement sa 7 voyez bien
qu'elle est absurde de se dire je vais
faire ça au théâtre
oui mais c'est vrai
mais ça fait partie oui ça fait partie
des inspirations avec d'autres films
avec d'autres films d'ailleurs comme des
héros oui complètement will hunting
aussi pour la rencontre entre un jeune
surdoué est quelqu'un qui va changer sa
vie en se mettant à croire en lui en lui
donnant confiance plein plein de
références
du cinéma c'est vrai se retrouve dans la
pièce alors dans tous ses films que vous
venez de citer les femmes au déroulent
totalement secondaire voire sont
quasiment absentes et et ça vous empêche
pas que vous avez vous identifié au fond
non c'est vrai
parce que ça représente des aussi des
moments de l'histoire où
malheureusement les femmes avec moins de
place à la nasa par exemple elle en
avait on le voit d'ailleurs dans avec
eux avec des films aussi qui représente
qui parlent des femmes à cette époque là
mais c'est vrai que pour apollo 13 par
exemple c'est vrai ils sont assez
absente c'est pas le cas dans la pièce
d'un rémy et louis ils sont leur eau et
l on roule au sol au fond c'est elles
ont des rôles de femmes de cette époque
là oui exactement oui c'est ça colle à
l'époque est-ce qu'il ya d'autres épopée
comme ça vous avez envie de mettre deux
en scène décrire d'abord être mettre en
scène de théâtre où est ce que vous
pourriez demain écrire une pièce comme
la plupart des gens écrivent des pièces
aujourd'hui à trois personnages avec le
mari la femme et l'amant
c'est vrai que je suis très attiré par
le type des têtes que j'aime aussi aller
voir et c'est souvent des épopées des
grandes aventures donc je pense que
c'est ce que j'ai envie de faire
même temps ausy à chaque foyer bon avec
six comédiens on peut faire 30
personnages mais la limite aujourd'hui
c'est le nombre des comédiens ça coûte
cher des comédiens sur scène au fond
c'est ça la limite du théâtre à
aujourd'hui oui complètement après la
sur cette pièce comme sur celle de gamme
comme sur les crapauds fou j'étais
accompagné par des producteurs qui sont
complètement fous et qu'ils sont prêts à
programmer à produire des spectacles
avec nos facteurs six acteurs donc c'est
merveilleux c'est vrai que c'est plus en
plus rares
tendance à être un peu plus prudent en
général mais je relisais sabban le
théâtre de marcel aymé que j'aime
beaucoup et à l'époque qui avait il
écrivit des rôles pour quinze
personnages alors là aussi il y avait
sept huit hectares qui se partager
certains faisant refaisait plusieurs
rôles le passant la jambe police d'état
mais à l'époque on écrivait des
dialogues pour des passants par exemple
s'il n'existe plus aujourd'hui au
théâtre vous vous pourriez vous voyez ça
il ya des mini démunis des mini rôle
aussi dans la pièce est un personnage
qui a deux phrases voilà mes kitty qui
apporte quelque chose à la pièce avec
jonas pour apporter un peu d'humour
apportée et donc ces permis par par le
jeu des acteurs en fait les tous les
acteurs sont vraiment bluffant dans la
pièce il se veut il se transforme
vraiment d'un personnage à l'autre il ya
un côté transformiste aussi dans ce
nouveau théâtre dans celui de michel est
aussi parce qu'il ya des personnages
qu'on retrouve quelques minutes plus
tard ils ont complètement changé
d'apparence d'ailleurs la pub vantant ne
les reconnaît pas complètement souvent
j'entends à la sortie des spectateurs
dire c'est incroyable on s'est rendu
compte seulement au salut en fait qu'ils
étaient seulement 6
c'est vrai qu'ils sont ils sont tous
sont incroyables de mon lait ouais on y
lit sur leurs visages même se transforme
la course des géants c'est donc tous les
soirs à 21h au théâtre des béliers
parisien le dimanche à 15 heures bah
écoutez je vous souhaite bonne chance
pour la suite et j'attends la prochaine
pièce qu'une telle épopée vous nous
raconterez merci merci d'être venus mais
le dit morey
[Musique]
car le pl est vous avez sorti votre
premier rhdp en mars et vous ouvrirez
vendredi prochain le festival essonne en
scène par les francofolies ce domaine de
chamarande voici la photo vous avez
choisi pour illustrer notre époque non
ça n'est pas la fiche c'est celle ci
pourquoi les cas passés de photos de
chats oui mais justement mais c'est vrai
que quand j'ai vu cette photographie ce
qui m'a interpellé en premier c'était le
regard du char en fait céline de tisons
est exactement et s'est engagé chez moi
une inflexion sur baie le regard qu'on
porte sur soi et le regard aussi de
l'autre sur soi et c'est pas que c'est
quelque chose je crois qui est
omniprésent dans la société dans
laquelle on vit alors évidemment avec la
publicité avec la télévision mais aussi
avec les réseaux sociaux parce que c'est
quand même la spécificité de notre
époque vos textes aussi je pense
exactement ouais c'est vrai et justement
j'ai trouvé ça intéressant parce qu'en
plus le ch a effectivement fait vraiment
partie intégrante des réseaux sociaux
avec les est maudit mais aussi parce que
voilà il est reproduit avec un michel
forte quad et je suis toujours demandé
pourquoi le chien et ben je pense que le
shass et
tout simplement en fait c'est un animal
du quotidien qui est qui et qui est
gentille a une connotation positive qui
est doux que les gens aiment en fait
énigmatique aussi non le chat il est
quand même moins fidèles que le chien il
se laisse -
est-ce que c'est pas son mystère aussi
inquiets lors attachant avec le chat il
veut encore plus ancien que le sphinx et
qui sait des choses que même le 5
seniors à on va leur demander alors je
vois bien qu'on en parle d'ailleurs sur
les réseaux sociaux mais j'ai allemand
se contente de compter des photos
alors vous serez donc au domaine de
chamarande
votre douche alors je propose pour ceux
qui ne vous connaissent pas encore qu'on
regarde tout de suite un extrait de
l'huile blanche à des morceaux qui
figurent sur votre 1ere p
ce soir je suis seul régime alumine club
j que ça va me rendre malade mais je
vais y quand même je suis seul ce soir
j'enchaînerai bien les vers chic sa
maman mauvaise mais je le ferai quand
même je vais le regretter je sais j'ai
regretté je le sais je vais là mon vtt
de nous
je vais le regretter je le sais je vais
regretter je le sais je vais londres et
était de nos pieds de moi
qu'es-tu futaba en effet si tu sentes a
pas montré t'as pas honte pour manon
tapas mon mari film je suis pas bien je
suis une erreur mais je préfère croire
et on pourra jamais atteindre
bah ouais j'ai bu je suis pas bien je
suis lumière tu préfère croire qu'un
poids jamie m'attendre je m'entends plus
ya peu près combien 10 voix dans ma tête
qui me sont un
peu dépassés par la situation
constate qu'un problème
ça me
tue c'est triste moment où sera l'unique
leurs poches sont sexy mal mais je vais
quand même tu sais c'est ce moment où je
me sert un verre et qu déjà malade mais
je vais quand même je vais le regretter
je sais je vais le regretter je le sais
je vais entrer dit et de mots
et je les regrette et je le sais je le
dis je
[Musique]
en cause des découvertes car le plein je
me suis mis au point ne fait pas de la
musique et le fait de l'art contemporain
et après je vais vous aviez fait les
beaux-arts donc ce qui tend à confirmer
qu'avez vous fait de l'art contemporain
superbe et ça me fait plaisir c'est que
c'est que du coup ça fonctionne et qu'on
sent cette influence et aux foules chez
l'impression que la musique c'est ce qui
vient tout à la fin le texte d'abord
l'idée l'interprétation
le clip pas tout ce qui va autour de la
mise en scène auto et font que la
musique secondaire alors cemex ici c'est
plutôt une très bonne intuition dans le
sens où c'est vrai que moi ce qui est
venu en dernier finalement dans mon
parcours artistique ça a été la musique
est avant effectivement il ya eu de la
lecture et l'écriture après il ya eu les
beaux-arts et après il ya eu la musique
donc en effet
ça passe plutôt dans cet endroit là mais
j'espère quand même que ça fait un
ensemble ça fait un ensemble et il ya
même une unité on va regarder tout de
suite un extrait de rien ne vous
raconter qui figure également sur ce
premier ep on va voir que effectivement
il y à il ya une parenté une familiarité
voir une intimité on vous regarde
[Musique]
si sa tante
m
ce trio jussie c'est maintenant ou
jamais je devrais pouvoir l'écrire mais
j'ai trop la gorge qui sert à les
caresser tendrement ou jamais tu sais
pas lire ou tu as peur tu ton ombre kg
banque elle signe ou des modes dans ma
faim oui j'y reviendrai pas j'ai
beaucoup beaucoup la gorge qui je veux
plus s'incrire te sens tout le monde
s'inquiète ce n'est pas tout écrire que
rôle d'agent rien rien à raconter j'ai
pas besoin
rien sinon à vous raconter j'ai rien
rien rien raconté gilles parfum chez
rien
[Musique]
c'est sur l'intimité c'est sur
l'intimité et spécifiquement avec ce
clip que justement j'ai tourné chez moi
là j'ai voulu j'ai voulu ouvrir un peu
plus mon univers est aussi vous montrer
un peu plus et qui j'étais moi parce
qu'il ya toujours cette posture de
l'artiste qui on est dans la vie et tout
ça est et avec ce clip j'ai voulu voilà
essayer de faire coïncider les deux au
maximum donc oui c'est intime on a
l'impression que vous êtes la seule à
dire ce que vous pensez parce qu'en
général dans les clips en faire on
imagine bien que le chanteur pense qu'il
dit mais pas parce qu'il chante mais pas
à ce point là vous vous en faites
peut-être parce que vous dites des
choses qui vont l'air anodine oui et
bien en fait tout ça c'est très bien mon
processus d'écriture moi je moi en fait
j'ai envie de
de créer et de livrer un art qui soit le
plus proche de ma pensée déjà à la base
et cette pensée là elle quand elle
surgit en fait elle surgit en un jet et
elle est vraiment complètement
authentique je retouche très peu mais
texte après et souvent c'est dans des
moments justement de prise de conscience
des choses où je suis tout seul et où
j'écris comme ça et je pense que c'est
ça qui qui fait qu'ils donnent cette
intimité qui livre qui livrent ce à quoi
y'a rien à raconter c'est toujours un
peu gênant de l'avouer oui la plupart
des gens ont envie de dire des choses
mais au fond ils ont rien à dire
vous vous dites oui c'est mon cas oui
c'est mon cas oui c'est mon cas parce
que je sais pas moi ça me semblait
important dans cette période où
effectivement je commençais à écrire le
p parce que cette chanson elle est
intervenue à ce moment-là de finalement
être totalement transparente par rapport
aux conditions aussi de création un
petit peu ça se fait aussi beaucoup
d'ailleurs dans l'art contemporain de
dévoiler le processus et c'est donc ça
c'est quelque chose aussi qui vient de
l'information qui me vient des
beaux-arts et qui pour moi aussi assez
naturel du coût et du coup cette chanson
voilà ce qu'elle raconte elle raconte la
crise de la page blanche et finalement
devient une oeuvre avec cette crise là
mais alors ce qui est drôle c'est quand
on voit ses clips et d'autres aussi
d'ailleurs parce que tous ont cette
unité ou pourrait croire voulait fait
tout seul avec un téléphone portable est
en fait il se trouve qu'il ya aussi les
vikings boeuf qui sont disponibles quand
on cherche vous offre sur internet et on
s'aperçoit que c'est pas du tout c'est
presque une superproduction son cours va
regarder un extrait du making of mais du
dernier clip que l'on vient de voir air
a raconté que gmail dit tout à l'heure
regardez le making of qui a beaucoup
plus de monde qu'on croit
[Musique]
si j'ai beaucoup trop la gauche tel fond
du fond je reparte sans qu'un bassiste
carole king même s'il ya un
cap et humains tant que je suis seul
face à moi-même bas
meilleur tarif toujours la même idée j
street à qui tournent toutes autour de
moi même un genou le monde cherche une
raison d'exister j'aime pas de refrain g
[Musique]
j'ai vu un réalisateur yann scénographe
nos foncez vous aussi qui les dirigeait
ses clips j'imagine tu leur laisses epal
la bride sur le cou non non en fait moi
sur le clip je me crédite toujours
quasiment en directrice artistique dire
qu'en fait en gros déjà je m'occupe de
la de la production des clips donc de
rassembler de rassembler déjà toute
l'équipe de m'occuper des plannings
c'est des gens qui sont arrivés à
collaborer en fait avec mon projet au
fur et à mesure du temps tu commencer
par les beaux-arts après j'ai élargi à
d'autres grandes écoles d'art donc c'est
aussi des amis en fait en vérité
effectivement suite après je m'occupe de
dirigé artistiquement le clip c'est à
dire voilà de poser toutes les grandes
idées d'en discuter avec eux tous les
gens qui sont intéressés par le sujet et
ensuite on défini ensemble ce projet je
pense qu'il a il a aussi un intérêt
artistique dans le sens où il est
vraiment fait fait sur mesure par
rapport à justement une direction
artistique ce qui n'empêche pas les gens
d'avoir leurs pattes bien évidemment
puisque c'est aussi pour ça que je vais
choisir c'est pas juste des exécutants
c'est déjà aussi qu'ils sont brillants
qui ont beaucoup de talent et leur
univers et du coup en fait c'est faire
coïncider tout ça et ça donne en fait ce
résultat là effectivement ça fait
beaucoup de monde on va regarder un
extrait du dernier clip cbi j'ai la
chanson figure enfin la chanson vous
appelez ça comment dire un morceau j'ai
une chanson une chanson bonus une
chanson donc qui figure également sur ce
premier rhdp est bon regardez un extrait
au fond ça raconte un moment de votre
vie très particulier est juste il faut
alors que c'est votre maman qu'on voit
dans le clip et qu'elle ne savait pas ce
qu'elle allait entendre dans l'est dans
les écouteurs on regarde un extrait de
biche et ça fait un moment que j'attends
donc j'ai voir si j'ai un peu peur de ce
que ça va lui faire comme comme émotion
pas vrai comme chaque probable c'est
possible bien aussi peur qui se passe
rien du tout est-ce que se passe rien du
tout on n'a pas de clip tu as donc voilà
j'appréhende un peu mais je pense que ça
va bien se passer
[Musique]
mettre des écouteurs maintenant
aux radios ok avec mon père en ce
discernement
[Musique]
souviens toi quand même tout ce que tu
as traversé
tu te demandes ce que tu fous là leurs
jours en inquiète pas c'est pas toi qui
vise à doter tout à fait normalement
tempête continue ses déceptions ses
angoisses tu te jure aujourd'hui l'air
accueillera ce serait plus grave tu
penses que tu fous là alors je comprends
un peu inquiétant pas dites moi c'était
le courage te faire plus
quelque chose qui va pas
j'ai mal là
[Musique]
la joindre a toujours toujours
à chaque
tour ce délai
alors j'invite à le regarder en entier
sur internet mais enfin on comprend que
vous a cru morte à la naissance et que
c'est quand même un peu cruel de faire
revivre ça votre mère
c'est vrai que je vois là aussi une
surprise donc c'est vraiment quelque
chose voilà d'une bonne intention je la
connais c'est aussi assez pour savoir
que ll le prendre comme ça à après
effectivement ce qui est un peu gêné a
peut-être pas acheter dire qu elle mais
ce qui était un peu compliqué c'est que
le piège de la performance parce que
sinon il se serait rien passé c'est
qu'elle ne connaissait pas la chanson et
du coup de lui faire revivre
effectivement ces moments là en plus je
l'avais enregistré elle ne le savait pas
puisqu'elle effectivement ce que la voix
qu'on entend dans la chanson c'est elle
que j'ai enregistrée sur ce sujet sans
qu'elle le sache quoi et c'est vrai que
en tout cas ça nous a créé beaucoup
d'émotion nous sur le plateau
franchement il n'y avait pas une mouche
qui voulait on était tous comme ça parce
qu'on voyait toute la séquence en entier
le moment voilà on a senti l'émotion
monte chez elle et c'est toujours ce que
cette fois là les larmes aux yeux à la
guerre dans visual fc la même qu'un
téléphone pour the voice mais quand on
gagne dit oui alors d'accord
je pense que qu'on verse pas tout à fait
le même ni d'émotions enfin mon oui
d'accord il y avait des larmes et oui
oui c'est vrai que du coup on a tous été
très ému et puis aussi soulagé bas par
rapport à ce qu'il dit au début du clip
du fait qu' il ya une situation qui se
créé parce qu'en fait c'était vraiment
sale on joue du clip et qui a beaucoup
de monde aussi sur le plateau quand on
soit le making off aussi on croirait que
vous n'êtes que toutes les deux bancs du
tout non pas du tout mais la question
que j'ai envie de vous poser puisque
vous serez sur scène en plus dans un
très beau jardin avec un château
vendredi prochain au domaine de
chamarande quand qu'est ce que ça donne
sur scène carole plaît jégo vous allez
me demander ce mamère sera nulle et
imagine alors la réponse est oui mais
qu'est ce que ça donne sur scène et bien
pour l'instant en fait nous ce qu'on
travaille beaucoup là mon équipe
disons scénique pour l'instant c'est un
duo sur scène pourquoi moi je suis en
fronte devant avec un musicien et je
travaille aussi le live avec un metteur
en scène et un chorégraphe est donc pour
l'instant on travaille vraiment le texte
et l'interprétation avec avec les moyens
qu'on a à ce stade de développement du
projet et l'idée par la suite si j'ai
cette chance là ça serait effectivement
de pouvoir voilà raccorder l'univers
visuel à l'universel nick donc là
peut-être effectivement mettre de la
vidéo travailler la lumière travaillée
la scénographie pour avoir un show
qu'ils soient en cohérence avec tout cet
ensemble aussi de l'image quoi pour
l'instant à quelle heure vendredi à 18
heures et 18 heures donc il fera jour
oui il fera george duke a écouté très
bon concert merci d'être venu carole
pelé mère s'appelle votre premier op est
sorti en mars et là c'est au festival
est seul en scène labellisée maintenant
par les francofolies d'ailleurs au
domaine de chamarande merci de nous
avoir suivis et rendez vous au prochain
numéro
[Musique]